chief weather capsule Lonnie Quinn of
our New York station WCBS is here with a
look at how it can be so destructive
Lonnie good morning well good morning
everyone as urban is clearly showing us
every element in a hurricane can be
dangerous but with Irma we really have
to focus on the winds and the storm
surge now just outside of the eye is the
eye wall this is where you find the
strongest winds of all with Irma the
hundred and thirty mile-per-hour winds
or confined to a very small area it's
just 15 miles from the eye so wherever
that eye makes landfall that's where
you're gonna get the most devastating
damage now outside of this there's
another band of hurricane-force winds
they extend an additional 65 miles and
here's where you find winds that are
about 74 miles per hour or even stronger
and the rest of that storm is filled
with tropical storm force winds those
are winds over set over 39 miles per
hour and they go out boy a hundred and
ninety miles but keep in mind you could
always get stronger gusts basically
anywhere in that storm it also matters
what side of the storm that you're on
now the worst part of storm to be in is
the front right quadrant and that's
because the peak winds are made worse by
the forward progress of the storm this
is also the part of the storm that
spawns the most tornadoes and that's
what we have seen already today now the
back right quadrant of the storm brings
in the most storm surge in this
particular case because the water is
going to be pushed into the west coast
of Florida Nora all right Lonnie thinks
as always for that great information